all right welcome everyone to the ddps
seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all uh please
mute yourself during the talk um but if
you have questions you can unmute and
ask questions or use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in Q&A session at the end second
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audience um so no classifi discussion is
allowed here and finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me briefly introduce our speaker today
um it is an honor to host Dr Boris
krammer who is an assistant professor in
mechanical and aerospace engineering at
UC San Diego prior to joining UC San
Diego he spent four years as a
post-doctoral associate in the
department of air Aeronautics and
astronautics and Aerospace computational
Design Lab at MIT he received his
master's degree and PhD in mathematics
from Virginia Tech prior to that he
studied mathematics in technology and
mechanical engineering at the University
of c um
what K in Germany yeah Germany thank you
for and he uh is a member of the uh San
and a senior member of AI AA where he
also served on the multi- disciplinary
design optimization and is active in uh
non-deterministic approaches Tech
approach technical
committees he is an 2022 NSF career
award and won a Department of Defense
Newton award in
2020 his research is funded by the
Office of Naval Research resarch the
defense um Advanced research project
agency and the N National Science
Foundation his research interests are to
develop computational methods and
numerical analysis for control
optimization design and uncertainty
quantifications of complex and large
scale systems all right today Boris will
talk about structure preserving learning
of high dimensional lagrangian and
hamiltonian systems please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk um now let me
ask a couple of questions so that um you
know to make this seminar somewhat
informal okay first question for you bis
um obviously you are uh very passionate
about you know um you know computational
methods and numerical analysis for
control optimization and also I know you
are really into redu do models um is
there any moment in your life when you
realize wow this is it this is the field
I would like to commit my career uh do
you have that moment and if you have
would you share that moment with us um
maybe to to understand a question was
there a moment where I said I found my
career I'm happy and I'll stay doing it
yes yes yes okay um yeah I kind of did
that when I was uh I think maybe an
early Master student um starting my PhD
I did an internship somewhere in
industry and it really wasn't wasn't
thrilling me and I felt like there so
many things to keep answering and to do
uh research on that I wanted to kind of
go in this direction and that High
Fidelity models are everywhere but
they're not always super practical so
reduced order modeling is it awesome all
right well second question for you um um
as we all heard the you know the
introduction about you like you've been
getting a lot of hours and and fundings
from various resource uh sources um in
the sense you've been quite successful
um as an assistant professor as a ear
career already that's a wonderful job
any secret any hint for future faculty
you know person people yeah it's um very
very good question I thought you gonna
ask me if the 49ers win the Super Bowl
but um no
uh I I think um you know a lot of us is
keep talking to people um listen to the
big trends that are happening um there's
so many great areas to work in at the
moment it's equally important to work on
a great problem as it is to work on a
good solution and I think combining both
will um has worked well but uh you know
it's I think it's a good starting point
good application and good good
application and good methods yeah good
good tip and good hint okay the floor is
yours Boris absolutely thank you so much
yungo for inviting me here um to give
this remote seminar and for all the
attend who I don't see I don't have the
tiles up here so if you're here and um
you know I hope it's not U some of it is
to your interest um my collaborators on
this work are diverse so we have um from
different departments uh we have uh M
the main driver of all of this work is
uh my post Dr har Sharma he been
involved in all the papers you'll see
today in the methodological development
and then also started collaborating a
lot more outside of our department um
with these uh two man Iman um who's a
graduate student here and Mike tly
they're both roboticists U with David
njera and Miche Al tot they're from
Structural Engineering um they have some
interesting applications that they want
to use our methods on and then um XU
Wang is a collaborator of ours on the
methodological site at the University of
South Carolina um this work's been
funded uh by DOD Newton um so by
Department of Defense uh by the National
Science Foundation by the Korean
Institute for the advancement of
technology and for the by the office of
Na
research um to get us started I think we
all know uh in this seminar that data is
becoming more and more accessible we can
produce more data we can store more data
and the question is as engineers and
physicists how can we harness um this
this data and learn valuable things from
it while not throwing everything that
we've developed over the last 100 years
away um data is often High dimensional
um but High dimensional complex systems
often take very long to run so um the
goal here is if we do have um systems of
the kind that I have here dynamical
system that evolves in a nonlinear way
and might have complex inputs um inputs
acting C uh on a certain way on the flow
of the system then what can we do um to
learn such systems from data um we can
obviously do machine learning um I'm
interested in a few other methods um to
get us really into the predictive regime
of these things um in general large is a
topic of discussion that we could
discuss for an hour now what is large
but you know if n is reasonably large
here in my case over a thousand then uh
most learning methods will not be able
to learn in Thousand dimensional space
there will be some sort of a reduction
um needed in all of these methods um my
point is and many of us would would
probably agree in the seminar for
physical systems we have to incorporate
knowledge that we know so let's build on
what we know and let's really combine
The Best of Both Worlds um now I want to
talk specifically about structured
systems um systems that have something
more than just something uh mathematical
that we know about them that's just we
don't just know that they're having
quadratic or a cubic term but we might
know that it preserve certain things uh
for example there could be conservation
laws that are underlying most of
physical systems of their derivation
simple acticity reversibility
interesting configuration spaces showing
you a few on top here um plasma if it's
engineered or solo plasma has these
properties um I'm showing you later
something about self- robotic fish
mechanical system second order
systems and um maybe there's a long
history in modeling these things to
incorporate a geometric structure to
discretize them correctly in space and
in time and therefore to get predictive
simulations for such problems only have
yet is that these predictive simulations
can be quite
expensive what happens the the time
integrators are generally quite
expensive they might be implicit and the
system Dimension is large to comp to
cover complexity and so what what I'm
interested in and what we'll be talking
about it here is um there's a need for
physics preserving not just informed but
physics preserving reduced order
modeling so something that brings down a
dimension but also preserves the physics
I'll structure this in two parts uh the
first part we'll talk about hamiltonians
and the second part we'll talk about
lonians I'll hope to spend more time on
the second part um and two uh citations
are here I'll also have them up later
again if you're interested in this so
I'll start a little bit um more General
with gradient systems uh actually this
this is a typo here should be a general
infinite dimensional gradient system
where I have a a field wide that
interested in X is my spatial variable
um T is a time and basically the
Dynamics uh as it evolves in time is
governed by a linear differential
operator and then a variational
derivative of this functional H and here
in my talks specifically I'm breaking up
H into things that have quadratic nature
and things that have higher order polom
or non-p polinomial
nature now if this L has a specific
structure for example if it's skew joint
then we often refer to this system as a
hamiltonian system the hamiltonian will
remain constant and we call um the
partial differential equation
conservative um if L happens to be
negative semi-definite or negative
definite um then we can refer to um H as
an energy function or as a leop function
and we could have either respectively
non-increasing Behavior or a
monotonically decreasing behavior and we
would call the PD
dissipative in structure preserving
space discretization then you take this
PD and you move to an OD and you would
give an OD that looks as follows where
basically this gradient of this H
hamiltonian or lapina function appears
and where D has a very specific
structure now this is all in very high
dimensions and we're trying to reduce
the dimensionality so given some
trajectory data why at certain time
steps I would learn would like to learn
the evolution um of the system so I'd
like to get a dynamic systems repres
representation that works in lower
Dimensions so it's um faster to
execute to go back to the gradient
systems for a second there's special
cases obviously so when um B is Q
symmetric Q joint anti- symmetric any of
the three words you can you might be
familiar with um which really means D is
minus D
transpose uh then we call this a
hamiltonian and what we can show is that
for any times um such that T1 is less
than T2 um
the hamiltonian is conserved so the
hamiltonian evaluated at the flow y of
T1 minus the hamiltonian evaluated at at
the solution at time T1 so T2 minus T1
if you work out the integral well the
skew symmetry is exactly what gives you
the zero here um so you have
conservation and this is what we want to
track in numerical solution if D happens
to be negative semi uh definite or
negative definite then you have a gr
gradient flow system and you have a
dissipation so um the hamiltonan uh a
solution of time T1 minus or the energy
at T1 minus the energy at sorry T2 minus
T1 uh would be less than zero so the
system dissipates
energy um and numerical schemes if you
want to do just PD discreditation they
would respect this and we want to
respect these properties in reduced
order data driven
modeling so let's focus on this talk on
canonical hamiltonian systems um just
for the purpose of the first 10 slides
uh in Canon systems I can separate uh
the state into U two distinct physically
interpretable uh interpretable
quantities the momentum and a
generalized
momentum The Matrix that's in front of
the gradient of the hamiltonian uh is
the simple canonical um hamiltonian
structure it looks like the identity
minus the identity on the Alp diagonal
and um and lastly there's a a symmetry
that we can often use in the full auto
model operators um that arises from
space discritization if you're
interested in other gradient systems
then you should look at this if you're
interested in specifically non-canonical
hamiltonian system then um uh Anthony
Gruber and and um Irina who I think is
on this call um have done some work in
this area to do uh learning of these
systems so canonical case um what we
would like to do I would basically like
to learn a system of the top part uh
that looks like Q do p dot uh is equal
to that but I'd like to reduce the
dimensional lity first I don't want to
learn in in a thousand Dimension so to
do that I assume I have data um I store
snapshots of full order simulations in
The Matrix q and P just to separate
these physical
quantities I have assumed here in this
talk and we'll relax assumptions as we
got further into the talk and this first
part I'm assuming that I know something
about the nonlinearity in the functional
so I know something at the PD level I do
not have to know this at the code level
but I have to know it at the PD level if
I know this then I can evaluate um
non-quadratic terms uh on my state so I
can build these forcing matrices both
for a momentum and a generalized
momentum and I can also build time
derivatives with a finite for example
finite differencing scheme um if I have
noisy data then maybe have to do
something else um total variation
differentiation or something else but
what I do here is I store data I I
evaluate um something that I know at the
PD level and I um compute time
derivatives now I have to reduce my
dimensionality because n could still be
in the thousands or 10 thousands or 100
thousands to do this um here we have to
be a little bit more careful so we want
to use proper simplec decomposition that
was you know um proposed in this paper
by Pang and Main in
2016 so basically you want to make sure
that the projection is onto the the
right space so that this um that this
projected Dynamics can still be um
evolving in a simp simplec flow so here
the way to do this is um you basically
compute uh this F Matrix you set these
two projection Matrix e equal to this F
Matrix and you get this from this
cotangent lift
algorithm now you project you project
your States linearly again this is not
Auto encoders nothing else here you can
project your States linearly you project
the time derivatives linearly and you
project the forcing linearly we have
done other work where we looked at
manifold um expansions here but for now
in this talk we'll just focus on linear
projections so now I have projected data
um and I need to figure out what do I do
with this projected data so I know now
that um this data lives in a low
dimensional Subspace um I've established
that now in that low dimensional
Subspace I impose a
hamiltonian um so if I work were to
write things down on paper I would
arrive at the case that my hamiltonian
the low dimensional Subspace would look
like this um it would have you know a q
transpose DQ Q hat there would be an
equal part with with um the P variables
and there would be my nonlinear terms
now I would also know um from this
expression these are scalers the
Hamilton is a scalar function that DQ
and DP has to be symmetric um and that's
a knowledge I have to embed in my in my
optimization I would not see this if I
go directly to the to the um to the
governing equations so so here in the
hamiltonian this becomes evident and so
therefore we carry this through um my uh
State Dynamics are now given as
follows okay so now I have Dynamics uh I
have a hamiltonian um and now I would
like to base this off of basically this
operator inference framework that
Benjamin pierer and Camin Wilcox um uh
worked on in 2016 uh which is a really
great and flexible framework to um to
efficiently learn low dimensional models
so now what we do here since in this
part of the talk I made the assumption
that I know what the at the PD level
what what non polinomial terms I have I
put everything I know on the left hand
side I put things that I don't know on
the right hand side which are these
operators I constrain my optimization by
symmetry conditions and all I have to do
is solve for these two um these Le SES
problems actually separate um so I can
separate them um as follows for a
problem in p and in Q and the the pro
the solution to this problem is actually
given um by a yapon of equation so you
can either minimize this with a solution
of your choice or you can solve a leop
of equation we found that solving these
leop of equations with um specific
symmetry conditions is kind of um a nice
way of doing
this okay so now we have a few operators
and um what we basically have now is a
reduced aut model we have learned these
operators had and we have a reduced
order model um that evolves the reduced
states with these um with with these um
symmetric matrices in linear
terms we studied this for a little bit
um in terms of what can we say so if you
had done reduced order modeling which is
projection based often if you had done
this in a gurin projection framework so
if you take your PD you discretise it in
space you multiply you you have um
reduced spaces that you want to project
it on so if you had done this would the
Learned model from the least SES problem
be close to the projected model if you
had done everything
intrusively and uh while it's not a
result that has a preasymptotic error
bound at least it's it tells us that the
The Operators that you get from
projection which we call Till The
Operators are close to the operators
that we get from learning uh by Epsilon
and the Epsilon kind of so for every
Epsilon you can find an r that satisfies
this the unsatisfactory thing about this
result is that we don't quite know how
Epsilon depends on
R but anyway so in the in ASM totically
we have this result here that at least
we learned the right operators um very
recently we also um looked a little bit
at um the error that that implies now on
the solution so if you were to solve
your full order system from Z to T and
you solve your reduced system from Z to
T and you inject this reduced State back
into the full state with your Matrix
f um then you can bound this error by
using some gronell inequalities as
follows there's a constant that I'm not
going to go into details in but
basically the error has three component
there's a projection error that you have
in all linear methods um so the error in
the projection of your
state um you have so to speak a data
error um that tells you well how
accurate is your is your time derivative
scheme that you have
approximated and then this is really the
error we focus on more which is the
optimization error that tells you well
how well are you learning structural
properties of this um Dr Matrix that you
have
um and and this is something that we
study a little bit more in in this paper
not going to go much into it but I
wanted to tell you there's two types of
ways that we can bound the erors and
there's some lipshits um constants
involved that uh I I don't have defined
on the slide so just wanted to bring
this up so now I want to show you some
some uh results here um going right into
what can the hamiltonian operator
inference 2 uh let's assume I have a
cubic system cubic shinger equation um
which has the following time continuous
hamiltonian so the hamiltonian can be
broken up as we had it before into a
quadratic component and here we have a
quartic
component um this nevertheless does lead
to a canonical um hamiltonian PD where
we have this um canonical Matrix of one
and minus one um we have spatial
derivatives those are the things where
you typically need to understand what
spatial scheme has been used to discor
the PD into the OD and then we have um
simple multiplication of States like Q
^2 time Q cub and p^2 * Q those are
multiplications you can perform element
wise of on any discretized Vector okay
so that's what I mean these are kind of
spatially local terms and these are
terms that need um spatially neighboring
information to compute
derivatives um there's invariance of
motion that are known for this system so
we'll study those um the the mass for
example is conserved and the momentum is
conserved um and they're defined as
follows so you'll see some plots later
that look at these invariance of motion
um we mainly conserve the hamiltonian
structure um but they kind of will see
that um at least the mass is perfectly
conserved and the momentum is is very
well
conserved so for a reasonably low State
um Dimension here so uh 128 uh we look
at the state error um so the relative
state eror in training and in
testing um so in the testing regime I
think I didn't say what uh what kind of
times I'm looking at it'll become clear
in the next
plot but I'm doing a reduction to either
to even number of modes between two and
12 and I compare my learning method with
an intrusive method um intrusive proper
symplectic decomposition by peng and M
so if I had known everything and I
didn't have to learn it and I have full
access to my system this is the error I
would get and if I learn it I'm pretty
well until about 10 and then my error
flattens off um in testing we do pretty
well um comparable to the intrusive
method um which is quite well but keep
in mind you know the axes are different
the testing error of course is larger
than the training error here
okay um we'll look at the invariance now
uh or the hamiltonian first so we look
at how does the hamiltonian at the full
order model level uh evolve so H at VY
hats um so how does it evolve evolve and
how is it conserve um so if we look at
the full order model energy um you know
it's bounded by about 10 the minus 5 and
it evolves in the cyclic nature that
black line is the end of our training so
we train for 20 seconds and we test for
seconds it's important to notice that
since we maintain the structure even if
we go into the predictive regime that
structure is maintained the model
remains stable the model remains
predictive and and keeps its uh its uh
predictive capability so that's
important um not all methods uh
unstructured methods methods that don't
embed physics are typically not seeing
that um if we model the the
reduced um the reduced order model
hamiltonian um it's a little bit of a
different way of looking this we also
conserve this um for for dimensions here
but but really I think the full AA model
um is is the right way to look at it was
there a question I heard a a noise
someone have a
question I think it was Noise Okay good
um now we look at invariance so we look
at Mass conservation of momentum
conservation so um again we look at them
at the high dimensional level at the
full order model level um the momentum
on the right side is perfectly conserved
um you know down to machine Precision um
and the mass is conserved up to with an
upper bound of like 10 to the minus 6 uh
for the for our operator inference model
and the intrusive model actually
conserves it perfectly we did not bake
in any constraints to enforce that um
but that's kind of a byproduct of
learning the Hamilton instructure and
the simplecity
right okay so this uh wraps up my short
part about the first 20 minutes about
hamiltonians and I'd like to spend the
next 25 to 30 minutes focusing on lrin
um
and I'll take combined questions at the
end if that's okay just to make sure
we'll get through most of the stuff um
so now we focus on lanan models uh they
have uh structures as well and again
this methodologically this is based on
the work that har has done and then
we'll see several extensions and
actually nice
applications so why is neine structure
now important why is that something we
should focus on well you know classical
methods here um or a classical example
is you have a beam what transfers
vibrations you know it's vibrating it's
uh supported at both ends and you might
excite it and you start measuring the
viations of this um here it's a modeled
by an Oiler Bly B
model and now you could say well I know
I mean it's a mechanical system with
second order so I could learn a second
order system so I could do for example
this method called operator inference I
could just write X double dot is
something on the right hand side and
I'll just learn it um if you do that in
training everything would look perfect
to you because you're having a relative
State error plotted against a reduced
Dimension So you you're testing
different reduced models up to order 20
let's say and you see as you incre
increase the dimension um your model
error go your your um State error goes
down your reduced model in the training
data produces well um the result that
your full auto model does okay so now
you say well what is that any good um I
want to make predictions
um and you wouldn't see the error in the
prediction until a much longer time so I
think here we trained for like .05
seconds or or 0.1 seconds so the black
line is again indicating how long we
trained so we let this vibrate for a
little
bit and then we make predictions um so
you train and and everything looks good
here and for a while actually everything
looks good it looks like your energy
error is bounded by I don't know 10 the
minus 5 10 Theus
4 and then at some point at .8 seconds
that energy keeps growing which means
you just ran into this is a this is a
byproduct of you not conserving the
hamiltoni uh the lran property correctly
here the energy keeps growing Solutions
blow up in finite time and despite you
learning a second order system um you
have basically no predictive accuracy at
some point okay so we need to do
something let's look at the mechanics of
this problem um so here we look at right
down what lren Dynamics are we need a
finite Dimension we we're in finite
Dimensions now we need a configuration
manifold Q we need State space um TQ and
a lran l which again measures uh is a
scalar
quantity if we allow forcing uh we would
the the oiler lrange equations are
derived from this lran and external
forcings as follows we take the partial
of the lran respect to Q take the
partial of the lrin with respect to Q
Dot and we have a d over DT here and
then forcing act on the right hand side
um so if we now go to this is the
general form uh if we focus on simple
mechanical systems we would there's a
certain way that the lran splits and
that the kinetic and the potential
energy separate um and their dependence
on Q and Q dot so simple mechanical
systems the kinetic energy is uh
quadratic in um in this Q Dot and the
potential energy is quadratic in Q we
also know that we Again by these being
scalers that there would be symmetries
involved and and we have know something
about positive definites too forcing on
this slide I'm telling you uh that
forcing I model with simple dissipative
linear forcing um and U I allow a linear
time dependent input here as well that
acts on the system if I do this I arrive
at a simple linear second order system
but I know about this system that um K
has a symmetry that M has a symmet
C actually might also have a symmetry
depending on how I how I choose it um
and then I know that there's a linear
forcing acting okay so that's one way to
do this I can expand um and also use
this um oila lrange principle to look at
nonlinear wave equations so now I'm
going a slightly uh one level up so I'll
go to the pte so what if I have a wave
type equation um so second order in time
uh onedimensional in space um where I
have some nonlinear terms um you know uh
sign Gordon equations being one of an
example here so I have some nonlinear
terms here um that um act on the
potential
energy so UNL is really this this
nonlinear term in the potential energy
okay so if I were to discretise this in
space with with um a structure
preserving for example a symmetric
finite difference or pseudos spectral
methods then my space discretized
larangan would basically look at the um
the Q variables with respect to T it
would discretize um my spatial
derivative with a certain discretization
scheme that this is this Matrix D here
and I would have my um nonlinear
potential energy being subtracted here
this would all lead me this is where I
want to end up to a system that looks
like qou dot is KQ K has symmetry again
this is important um and nonlinear Parts
if I know that nonlinear potential
energy then I would get this
contribution by taking um that that uh
derivative um we know that this full
order model conserves the total energy
which is defined as follows okay um so
this is a principle that we also want to
quantities and qualities that we learn
from this we want to use in learn in the
model
learning um so usually when you start
reviewing you're you're never having all
of the work there's a large body of work
in the machine learning community that
has focused on lran systems for example
how can you learn them from images um
how can you learn them if you take
pictures of robots um I'm focusing here
on on the model reduction aspects and
what has been done there um seminally
intrusive uh projection based methods
for lran systems came out by the by
Jerry Marston in 2004 and Kevin calberg
and a group at um Sandia picked this up
in 2015 and did some really nice reduced
order modeling uh for nonlinear lren
systems um this was intrusively so we
want to look at non-intrusive things M
krmer has done EX excellent work there
and I believe he was a speaker in the
seminar series too um he uh did some
nice NE network uh work and then um
extract by incorporating lran systems um
and a couple of other people and this
list could in 2023 keep growing and
growing um we noticed that that many of
these look at very low dimensional
systems so we want to go to to Something
in the hundreds thousands tens of
thousands um operator inference is kind
of were War I feel is uh is is quite
flexible in learning these things so but
it doesn't allow for it didn't it wasn't
written with constraints to start with
um so really incorporating the lran
constraints just as we had done in the
hamiltonian case is what we'll be doing
in this work um there's also work that
came out pretty much um simultaneously
with our work on uh Opera inference for
linear mechanical systems This was um by
Peter Benner's group and Pavan coyal who
I believe was also a speaker in the
seminar series um so we will embed lran
structure into this operator inference
framework now and everything here will
look very similar to what I've done
before um again now I only have in the
lanan I just have um basically one state
I don't have to separate my states in
the PS and q's anymore I have a second
order system so I'm collecting State
data might collect output data I might
collect input data depending on if I
have inputs or if the output is
different from the
state I do now I don't have to proper
simplec decompositions I'm good with
just a single value decomposition I
project my data now I'm in the space
where I can learn things this is a
manageable Dimension R could be 10 20 30
and in this Dimension I still need
derivatives so I need a first derivative
and I need a second derivative and I
would compute them with some time
stepping scheme okay same thing as we
did before I would now look at well what
is it that that I need to conserve or
how would the Dynamics of the lren
evolve in the space so I write down my
lren principle um my lrin function um
very simple here as quadratic we will
change this to be nonlinear later and I
allow myself again A reduced forcing
that looks as
follows um and then I would again
recover a lran system that's second
order um that has certain properties for
example the symmetric K that allows for
forcing and has an in output and now
we're moving pretty much like before we
set up a constraint optimization problem
where we have uh constraints on K and C
to be symmetric positive definite uh and
things that we have pre-computed and
obtained from the data are Q double dot
Q dot q and u we know what inputs we
have um and then uh lastly we could
learn the output Matrix ehad if we
wanted to um we solve these things with
a constraint with um the CVX toolbox so
we minimize this problem problem under
constraints if you want to push it to
nonlinear wave equation so if you want
to add some nonlinearity here um then at
this point again we'll relax this at the
next level we we would have to know um
this component of potential energy at
the PD level if we do this then we can
evaluate our uh that nonlinearity at the
state we make the same projection and we
solve our optimization problem again
we'll see some results for this later um
importantly I think really the Symmetry
and positive definiteness is what gives
us a long-term predictive
accuracy if I do this with a sign Gordon
equation which is you know a
prototypical test problem for this which
has this nonlinear wave structure and
and a a non-p polinomial term on the
right hand side I'm comparing again
intrusive with non-intrusive so the
method we're looking at is a grin
operator inference um in training uh
which is 5 Seconds is good in testing
which is five times longer than the
training interval we're also doing very
comp comparable for low order um models
that go up to to uh R is equal to 15 um
again axes are different keep an eye
left is a state error for training
obviously that is much lower than a
state error for prediction okay um we
want to look at energy errors so um we
see that we have a bounded energy error
if we do this intrusively the bound is
somewhere in like 10 the minus 2 if we
do it non-intrusively with lran operator
inference we see some some cyclic
behavior and we would have a a larger
bound but again for long-term
predictions here um I'm showing you even
more so this was trained for 5 seconds
and tested for 25 seconds here we're
looking at 5 seconds and I'm showing you
that for 105 or 110 seconds we can make
stable predictions and I could run this
for 300 seconds if I wanted to um that's
really the the what the structure gets
you let's look at Solutions um they
there's uh certain wave type structures
solons that build up how do we do how do
we capture them so the full order model
at 5 Seconds that's the end of training
at 15 seconds and at 25 seconds that's
five times past the training interval um
we're doing pretty well here um the
green dots are basically showing what
the curve would look like after this and
we we capture basically this uh this
wave pretty well um okay so then we
wanted to say okay so this is a wave equ
and let's go back to a mechanical system
uh the motivating problem here was to
look at a soft robotic fish um we found
this in this um this is the group of
Daniel arus at MIT is doing a lot of
work on on Soft Robotics and so
basically this comes is explained nicely
in this paper so you have these little
fish and you want to actuate them and
really the actuation happens along the
center line of this fish this is the
important part um and so those are
swimming around you see a few snapshots
that uh some milliseconds taking from
these um uh simulations there obviously
um these are soft fish made from a
silicon type material so you really have
um you have a continum model here that
you have to deal with um there's a nice
um cat model that was developed by by
the group of Thomas Moyer um you can
find more about this paper from five
years ago and and basically there's this
just shows the actuation mechanism so
you see that tail here um the point of
interest um is kind of like the motion
um of the of this uh end point at the
center line um you have a certain Center
Line beam that is a reinforcement you
have a silicon Hull and then you actuate
um your Chambers sometimes by by
pressure sometimes um by the pressure of
a fluid pumping in okay so now we look
at the quantity of Interest which is the
this onedimensional quantity at the end
um so here I have like a sigmoid input I
look at uh I excite the the fish with a
with a sigmoid by the way the full order
model Dimension is 780,000 so this is
quite large um we have this displacement
and we show it for the high dimensional
problem and we show it for a reduced a
mod model of Dimension two that's pretty
good um other people have also worked a
group of Steph um Peter Benner Stephan
wner has has worked on this um with
different reduced order models is a
nicely reducible problem um relative
errors are
uh and the energy most importantly here
we train for one second extrapolated two
you see the energy doesn't change
anymore because we have a nicely
predictive
model um now we use a step input um so
this is an a a control in so so we
trained it with a sigmoid now we test it
with a step they have very different um
characteristics and frequencies that
they excite so even for different inputs
this works pretty well um we now see the
step response of the full order model
and of the two different reduced order
models um intrusive and non-intrusive
the displacement errors are probably
better here to see then to compare all
these circles and dots um and lastly the
F energy in both cases remains very nice
and stable um so so no energy cth or
anything okay um so that was our
Benchmark problem and by the way you can
download this is really nice um you know
Peter benners group has the more Vicki
up up so you can download this model if
you want to and play around with
whatever method you
have Okay so this was a benchmark model
so and and then some of our colleagues
here in the robotics group at UCSD got
interested in this and so now I'm just
showing you five slides or so about
actually building something like this
here at UCSD um so here I have some
videos I hope they're playing yungo
assured me they would be playing um on
the left side I'm showing you a video of
uh a trout that's swimming so this is an
actual experiment um where you have a
water tank you have a stream so you kind
of you know why do fish stream um swim
up the stream and you have to Trout um
swimming so let me
go oh now it doesn't let me see I'll
show it
again focus on the left video can
someone tell me what's the catch of this
of this left video if someone has seen
it you will know it if you haven't seen
it you won't know it uh or maybe make a
guess
the fish isn't alive the fish is not
alive yeah the fish is dead um which
which really is interesting they put a a
dead trout in there and just the the
body motion and the way these fish can
move allows them to swim with very low
energy like zero energy up upstream and
so that's pretty impressive obviously we
would like to replicate this in
engineering so on the right side you see
a video um that actually is from our
collaborators here at UCSD one building
over they built this soft robot they
actuated it with these um uh kind of
like pneumatic Chambers where they put
in pressur so these are the control
signals that you have so you have one
two three four five six control signals
I believe you have six controls that you
can actuate and you see this thing on
the right hand side is basically moving
um okay so that's that's that's good so
they want to actuate this thing um this
is a soft robots so uh you know it's a
Continuum model they there there's a
discretization software it's a little
tricky to use but we've used the two um
250,000 Dimensions nice thing is this is
typically segmented so they produce
individual segments and kind of patch
them together um if six controls um
which are these fluid elastomer
actuators they kind of also change the
actuators all the time to get better
performance and the outputs are the
center line trajectories um and and so
basically this is how this looks inside
uh the fin element model so now what
they want to do um is they want to do a
control Loop um more you have a control
policy that could be nonlinear so it's a
model predictive control basically
MPC um that goes into your robot your
robot is fully
nonlinear um you have output measurement
model which are the 40 points along the
center line and then you need a state
estimator um so from the output you need
to reestimate the state and the state
goes back into control That's a classic
control Loop this state estimation has
to happen in real time for this um for
this robot so that's where we want to do
a redu AA model um this is a simple
State estimator I mean controls people
love linear problems um so this is why
our operator inference method here will
look at learning a linear State
estimation model um so that they can use
it in control um and and again they
wrote it as a first order I mean this is
a time stepping we we kind of did like a
second order system here to get this um
discrete time system they ran it and one
of the things they found here so they
compared um they got a state estimation
they did a control policy and then they
kind of like actuated this robot one of
the things that they found in simulation
is a way to control this so they control
individual Chambers um separately and
they found that the the top segment has
to be actuated the heaviest and the tail
segment has to be actuated the least and
here's the actuation signals that would
come out if you use the norm of the
controls if you use um certain different
methods to build your state estimator
I'll talk about this later so what they
did um they compared three methods
dynamical mode linear methods because
they they need this to be linear and
fast um Dynamic mode decomposition with
control igen system realization or cman
identification er um and structure
preserving operator inference um what
they did did here on the on the right
sorry this is a bit grainy um they uh
compared IG system realization in open
loop and Clos loop operation dmdc in
open loop and closed loop and operator
inference in open loop and closed loop
and we look at a certain trajectory here
so the the zeroth output here and we
look at how this output evolves over
time and we see that with second order
operating inference we're doing a very
good job of tracking this um both in
open and closed loop uh so the state
estimator is pretty good um and the
resulting controllers so this is a good
model for for what they want to do um
and in the second this is in training
and this is in testing so as we go even
in the predictive scenario sorry again
it's it's it's kind of grainy um the
purple curves which are lran operator
inference really overlap with the ground
truth quite well this is as accurate as
a roboticist would would hope for this
to be um and then we do testing for we
randomize or they randomize the initial
conditions and run it for different
cases um so they get a root mean squared
area basically and they test in open and
closed loop and we see that uh Larin
operate inference does best um in all of
these test
scenarios now you ask yourself and and
this is where I take five more minutes
um to say okay so so everything was good
here our takeaways are that they seems
to be reasonable for the this
application that they have it works well
in open and closed Loom um
but there were a few data sets um where
the nonlinearity is just so strong um
that we need to do something about it
that even a linear State estimator might
not be good enough um and so in other
problems aside from the robotics
applications um for nonlinear waves I
showed you hamiltonian at the beginning
we kind of always had to make this
assumption that we know something about
the pte hamiltonian uh and that's not
fully satisfactory but that's what the
best we could do at the time um so now
you could ask yourself so then we
started working with um people in
Structural Engineering um they wanted to
use this method but they basically
enhanced this method to use some more
machine learning in it to avoid having
to know things because they work with
experimental data where they don't quite
know what the model is so now we augment
everything I've shown you
before um I'm looking again at the force
oil lrange equations um but I'm allowing
myself um BAS basically more
nonlinearity I allow myself to have
again a nonlinear component just like I
had before in the Lin setting I'm also
um allowing myself to have this
nonlinear component in there I have a
more General viscous dampling than I
allow myself here as well um so there
could be other damping terms that are
not just linear um and ultimately I
would come up with this lran system here
that now has highlighted in blue things
that we that we in collaboration with
our Structural Engineering colleagues
have added to this framework so we don't
have to rely on linearity again
linearity seemed to be fine for the
robots it's probably it wasn't fine for
the vibrational nonlinear vibrational
tests that um the structural engineers
were looking at okay so our optimization
problem now becomes a little bit harder
um it's not just optimizing over linear
constrainted operators anymore so not
optimizing over MC and k um but we also
have to optimize over these R these
functions now um so we would like to
find out which functions do we need
there um we split this up into two
things um the first part is we just
learn the linear parts so we learn um
the linear part of this problem C and K
so C and K and in the second step we
learn the nonlinear perturbations of
that problem okay and that's where we
use some structure preserving machine
learning um to learn the dissipation
function and the reduced potential
energy
functions so now you have to
parameterize the problem of course I
mean you can't learn over functions you
have to parameterize the function so we
um choose a Neal Network
representation um which uses actually
it's these uh multi-layer perceptrons um
that David felt like they were a good
way to use but we want to augment them
with polinomial too oftentimes you have
polinomial nonlinearity so if that's the
case you're doing a polinomial
regression here just of higher order not
with operator inference we learn linear
with this we would learn up to I think
fourth order pooms and if the
nonlinearity is still different from
that then these um MLPs kick in okay and
you can make this eth order if you
wanted to but um so we parameterized
this problem obviously now there's a lot
of free parameters we have to learn
these Alphas the lambdas the gamas um
and for the reduced kinetic energy we do
the same thing um we allow ourselves uh
so here we only use
polinomial um and that allows us to get
the a peration of the identity Mass
Matrix out which was previously um
something that we didn't have in the
framework by Computing the hen of this
energy okay and now I'll spare you the
cost function but the cost function is
basically this function over here we try
to minimize that error over everything
um such that we have structure
preserving constraints so we always um
want the energy to be positive we can
never get variables that give us
negative energies um and um you know we
want to do the same with like the
kinetic and potential energy so those
are the constraints that make this a
structure preserving method so in two
minutes I'll show you um the last
application which we're quite excited
about so this is the the half break Roy
beam um which is um you can access again
the data from um this website here uh
the method was described in this paper
um so basically what happens you have
two cameras high-speed cameras you have
a beam that's jointed in the middle so
you have a couple of bolts that go in
and jointing structure there's obviously
contact UM and friction and a lot of lot
of nonlinearity happen in the middle so
you cannot really understand so so
writing down the governing equations of
that joint is really hard um in modeling
it with linear is also not working so
that's why we're looking at nonlinear
methods so these cameras give you um
Digital Image um correlation
measurements um because there's like
sensors that are on top or kind of like
reflectors so you can measure things
right um of this beam and you get these
uh this nice data set in but at the same
time it's a beam so it's vibrating in
second order so we can incorporate that
so on the left side we're plotting now
this is a unusual plot I would say in
our community we look at um the position
versus frequencies so certain
frequencies of excitation uh frequencies
of the beam versus position and the
displacement amplitude um this is the
experimental data so this is the DIC
measurements that we have um and on the
right side so now we take these
measurements we learn a lrin operator
inference model that is linear plus a
structure preserving machine learning
model so a fully nonlinear Lin model we
predict things with order three and we
get what's on the right hand side um our
Structural Engineering colleagues are
very happy about this
um we can look at other things like
displacement amplitude position and
damping ratio um so what's the damping
ratio as a as a function of position as
you go up and down this half um this
half beam and we kind of recover that
pretty well too those are the same
scalings on the left and on the
right okay um that brings me to the end
of my talk before I go to the next slide
so these are what I wanted to show you
as um some experimental results as well
so before I conclude um let me use the
time to advertise um advertising a
conference that is very much in the
theme of this seminar series um which we
have in San Diego at uh on basically our
campus um so it's the model reduction s
good modeling conference it's running in
San Diego in September 9 to 13th if you
have nowhere better to be at that time
you should be here um it's a great time
to be in San Diego it's a great
Community um it's a single track
conference you know usually around 150
to 200 people um great way to mingle
with senior faculty Junior faculty meet
peers everything uh covers all aspects
of model reductions arrogant modeling
applications ukq design um you can sign
up by submitting a talk no paper
anything just a talk uh onepage abstract
um at this website uh applica and this
closes March 1st for graduate students
that are on here will also make
available pretty soon um uh some funding
that we have so that you can apply for
so to get um travel supplements to come
to San Diego so we can make this
affordable for all gra affordable and
accessible to all graduate students uh
and early career
postdocs so now I want to review I've
shown you that embedding geometric and
mechanical structure in the case of
hamiltonian lrin or other gradient
structures is is really great and it's a
way that people with physical and
Engineering knowledge um Can embed what
what they bring to the table um they
give us interpretable models that are
long-term stable um they're accurate um
and I haven't shown you this much but in
some of the papers we look at the need
for training data and we need less data
to train structure preserving things um
the methods I developed I want to
highlight they don't just work on a ond
test problem we've worked on them on
experimental problems from structural
mechanics experimental problems from
Soft Robotics and so they work pretty
well there which I'm very happy about uh
looking ahead I think you know neural
networks have great expressive nature
they're not as nice L interpretable that
as we found as um symbolic expressions
and so looking at more symbolic forms of
these nonlinearities would be something
we want to do and uh extrapolation in
parameter space is always a big question
so I'll take any questions here um and
thank you again for the invitation and
the last thing I wanted to point out is
that actually the one of the invited
keynote speakers is the host of the
seminar
you thank you Boris yeah I strongly
recommend all of you to join this
conference yeah
canot emphasize more thank you
Boris yeah and and also thank you so
much for the wonderful talk um that was
really nice let's have a Q&A
sessions um yeah there is a questions in
the chat and by
Jack um he asked would this approach
work for a high dimensional problem like
a molecules doing a full dynamical
calculations of even a small molecule is
very difficult
or even an atom a full calculation of
electronic structure has six n
Dimensions about
that yeah obviously I mean in some of
these uh I mean first of all you have to
identify if you know you have a
hamiltonian or a gradient structure or
lran structure that's something that
typically you you you would know from
the physics um dimensionality wise I
mean you you have to test you have to
run the simul first and see if there's
low dimensionality in it um which is
what what we do with um using the single
of Val de composition so if you see a
reasonable decay of singular values then
you have hope of doing this lower
dimensional I would expect that's the
case um but I I can't speak because I
don't know the application very well
right it really is uh application
dependent how the physics allow you to
approximate this right you have a um one
of the problem was solving the nonlinear
series equations and yeah yeah and you
know the first principle molecular
Dynamics people they are actually
simplify it and then come up with a DFT
like the density functional Theory and
um they solve it and um I guess there is
a you know connection between the
shingle equations and molecular Dynamics
MH maybe there is something here it can
propagate to could be yeah yeah and it's
certainly an area that needs it in terms
of dimensionality reduction yeah yeah
yeah and there structure preserving is
really important so
um so definitely there is a connection
so maybe I can ask questions um so you
you talked about the polinomial
augmentations at the end close to the
end and you triy the up to the fourth
orderer um well I guess you probably you
know studied lower order try the lower
order or higher order and then at the
the new
net was that WR right yeah yeah
basically I mean I think we stop
obviously the the higher order you make
it the more parameters you get to learn
um so there's a tradeoff between going
to 10th order and learning thousands of
parameters or going to keeping it at
fourth order um there was
some radio curve I I presume that we had
seen there that we felt um p is equal to
four is a good thing um but I don't have
the data at the moment I would have to
ask for this specific data set I would
have to ask uh David who who did that
that work why should be equal to four
good good so you have you know plotted a
par par front and based on that plot I
believe so yeah okay sounds good um all
right any other questions from
audience
our group is working on you know energy
conserving
intrusive model for Lan problems right
now um oh nice okay yeah but yours are
non-intrusive one the one you presented
today like using the
inance operator right yeah still I mean
what you do intrusive uh uh you know
maybe things can can be done non-
intrusively too
um yeah yeah that we should talk that
yeah
definitely because I mean in intrusive
in I mean we are specifically looking at
the Lan hydrodynamics and there ah okay
yeah and there we we get like super
energy conserving so if if you look at
the energy constraints 16 yeah like
almost like zero like 10 to 12 10 toga
13 yeah that's excellent and that's why
these methods are so I mean so great I
think yeah yeah yeah so we definitely
need to talk yeah I mean you know
intrusive is kind of the I don't know it
it really is if you can and and you guys
invest the time to go into your I don't
know what is it laros or whatever the
code you have yes yes yes yeah you you
go into it and you do it I mean that's I
would stick with that if you can
there's there's you know but um some
applications where you can you know
like those measurements we had or um
this the soft robotic stuff the software
is so hard to access that um we've tried
for half a year to to get it intrusively
and then we just gave up and said no um
yeah that's what happened with the
intrusive method usually yeah you
demonstrate really well in one uh
applications and you know in order to
apply that to other applications you
have to put pretty much same amount of
effort implementing it yeah I mean if
you have your own code it's perfect
because you understand it but if you
work with other people's code and what
we ran into that every time there was a
software update something didn't work
anymore so if you have your own code and
and you have control over that I think
that's the way to go then yeah yeah
totally agree um do you can you um
make some comment about you know the you
know
the one of the examples you compare the
dmdc and the your um the quadratic model
using the operator inference and you
know the speed up is comparable pretty
much yeah there I mean in that case they
were um this was
the oh this was in the robot stuff let
me see here they're all linear methods
so I mean there there's no difference I
mean it's just a different way that we
learn we have constraints in the way we
learn the linear method and we solve a
second order system DMD and and er are
first order like system ID methods but
once you have the once you have the
solution here I mean they're all in your
system so they're all pretty fast there
there's no difference um the only
difference I mean when we compare things
here um we compare actually the best
model that we can get from any one of
them so it could be that
you know DMD needs like 25 modes and we
need only 12 modes but we compare a 25
against a 12 mode system because we say
that's kind of like this is the best
model this is the best model so let's
let the two best models compete um but
nevertheless we we still find that going
understanding that there is second order
structure and symmetries is is really
what gets you
that awesome
awesome okay um is there any
questions from
audience don't be
shy they can email me too uh perfectly
happy with that yeah yeah
yeah well if not let's let's thank our
speaker today Boris um thank you so much
um it was wonderful talk and very nice
thank you definitely let's keep in touch
yeah um thanks for the invitations and
um thanks for everyone taking time this
morning awesome awesome thank you all
right by bye
Boris